so it seems that the future of Star Trek
is not Alex kirchman but Terry metallis
and Paramount are willing to put trust
in the young man following a very
successful season three Picard
I always get this great information when
I'm not at home
but let's go back to the studio out of
the wind and talk about it a bit more
welcome to Sidetrack your Sci-Fi TV
movie channel on holiday
[Music]
so if you're a regular site tracker
you'll know that I've been really lucky
enough to meet a few people that work in
and around the industry that get to feed
me bits of information and one of those
people has been speaking to me about
Star Trek and the future of Star Trek
now I've been hearing lots of rumors
over the last six to 12 months I've
actually Alex Kirsten is not
particularly well trusted with Paramount
Paramount Executives generally think he
makes big promises but then doesn't
necessarily follow through
now I had also heard a lot of rumors
that very early on in the showing of
Picard season 3 those concerns only grew
because the numbers for Picard season 3
were not great now don't get me wrong
the viewing figures weren't bad but when
a series like this costs a hundred
million dollars to produce as Picard
season 3 did
they were expecting a little more they
were at least expecting the card season
3 to get into the top ten
which he didn't
until week five when it jumped in at
number one now it seemed to me that
there was a little bit of a hangover
with us trackies we watched season one
we didn't like it we watched season two
and it actually made us bloody angry
because it made no bloody sense
and I don't know a lot of people were
like burn me once and burn me twice
I'm not watching season three until I
get an idea what it's like and that
seems to have been the case
people have come on board with season
three once they've realized it was not
going to be the show that season
one and two were so the numbers spiked
and this made Paramount happy but also
something that made Paramount happening
is the re-watch viewing figures where
people don't just watch an episode once
they watch it twice or three times and
those numbers are great now I will put
my hand up I'm one of those people I've
watched each of the Picard season 3
episodes at least twice I actually get
up early on Fridays here because I watch
it on Prime to be honest because I
long story I've got Paramount but I
can't seem to get on it but anyway I get
up early Friday I watch Picard season
three I go to work I come back and I
watch it again
Paramount love things like that this is
basically their equivalent to being able
to sell a show if if a show is
re-watched then it's got legs on it
it'll live for longer people won't just
watch it once and then forget about it
if they actually have a show that people
are still watching in two three four
years and they will occasionally come
back to oh that's the holy grail and
Picard season three seems to be one of
those shows oh that's at least what the
early signs say
so
the whole point of what I'm saying is
the Paramount Executives were not
massively Keen about actually keeping
secret hideout around for any future
Star Trek there was seriously
considering removing Star Trek from
secret hideout and going with another
production company now there's also the
issue that actually Paramount has to cut
spending they've been spending too much
money they're very open about that to be
honest the chief executive only came out
a few weeks ago and said look 2023 is
going to be the peak of spending after
that we're going to be spending less now
that is going to affect Star Trek like
it's going to affect lots of other TV
shows but Star Trek in particular is
quite expensive to make and right now
there are five series running that is
not going to be the case in the future
and we've already seen actually that um
Discovery season five the release date's
been pushed back the strange new worlds
release date has also been pushed back
the idea is to stretch the calendar out
a little bit so that there's not going
to be a massive gap between strange
world's Discovery and then a new show
coming they've spread it all out a
little bit so that's not quite so
obvious that they're going to be going
down to at least four seasons now I'm
hearing there's possibly only actually
going to be three seasons they've
actually lowered decks will get further
series they're very keen and very
pleased with that that strange new
worlds will get more seasons and that
there will be a third live action series
following the end of Discovery but the
prodigy even though I love it and
actually it's probably more Star Trek
than anything else on TV right now there
is a high risk that actually that might
not get renewed I don't think that
decision has been made just yet but
that's the rumor I'm hearing
but what about this new live action
series that is being talked about well
again Alex kurtzman has been out talking
about section 31 again he still seems to
think that they're going to get Michelle
yeoh to come back and do at very least a
mini series or maybe a small movie it's
not going to happen anytime soon if
that's the case Michelle yo is
incredibly busy and she is incredibly in
demand following her Oscar Victory so
section 31 with Michelle yeoh at least
seems like a no starter but what about
Star Trek 90210 as I keep calling it
because I hate this storyline idea but
Star Trek Starfleet Academy well the
idea that this show would follow on from
Discovery because at the end of the day
Starfleet is rebuilding and they're
going to need a new Starfleet Academy
that show will see the first class go
through and then maybe follow their
Adventures
I personally hate this idea I really
don't want them to do it now don't get
me wrong they could do it well and it'd
be brilliant but I think the entire
premise is flawed from the beginning I
don't think we like that sort of show I
think we want a monster of the week sort
of thing strange new worlds has proved
that actually you stick a crew on a
Starship and have a different Adventure
each week with maybe a storyline
intertwined but that doesn't dominate
the series is actually what we want to
see so if they go back to something like
Starfleet Academy it's a backward step
for me now the room I'm hearing though
is that Paramount producers have been
very impressed by Terry mattalis in his
work on season three
the reaction from trekkies has been
really impressive but also it's gained
new viewers which is even more
impressive again I have to keep saying
this is a rumor but the source I spoke
to is very aware that apparently this
conversation did happen on Thursday a
company from the outside was sourced to
do some work for Paramount this was
related to do Star Trek when they were
doing that meeting they were delivering
the results of that project they were
asked for their opinion on season three
and plans to move forward with a new
live-action series with Terry matalis as
the lead this outsourced company was a
marketing company and they were
literally just ask for their opinion
based on the work they had done looking
at the Star Trek franchise as a whole
during that discussion apparently
Paramount Executives raised the
possibility of moving forwards with
Terra matalis for a new series now
source is actually closer to terminalis
and I have to I will shout out the
podcast guys because one of them
messaged me straight away saying that
basically if this is true 10 metallis
doesn't know Alex gurson doesn't know
but I'm not really surprised by that
because they wouldn't know if this is uh
early discussion and they're just they
haven't really made a decision yet
they're asking this specialist company
that specialize in this field to raise
an opinion I would think that Paramount
needs to make the decision first and
then have the conversation with secret
hideout
now
what we do seem to know for certain is
that there will be less Star Trek coming
out of secret hideout in the future that
we will not be getting two series to
replace Picard and discovery that we'll
probably only get one we know it would
be very difficult for that to be section
31. we know chances are the fans might
not be massively Keen about a Starfleet
Academy even though it could be
brilliant don't get me wrong
so what is the other option well Terry
mattalis has been talking about this
Starfleet Legacy idea that he's had
where he would like to see you know
maybe some of the kids from some of the
TNG crew like Geordi laforge's daughter
and maybe Jack Kushner Etc appearing in
a new series moving forwards now LeVar
Burton has actually said very recently
he'd be well up for this idea
Patrick Stewart said this might not be
the end of Picard and that he might
return for some future project he can't
really return for section 31 because
that would be set in a different
timeline and he can't really return for
Starfleet Academy if that's set after
discovering so Patrick Stewart we can
assume I was maybe talking about some
other Legacy project
but also Marina certis and Gates
McFadden have both been on Twitter
before season three aired talking about
how this doesn't have to be the end of
the TNG crew and that if the fans want
it maybe something could come out of it
and they could return
for me that is the Legacy project
whether it'll be called that we don't
know whether it could be set aboard the
Titan with maybe seven of nine as
Captain or even sure if Captain if he
survives which I very much doubt he will
I would love that idea as well
we have got a new Enterprise on the way
could that make an appearance we just
don't know but again fans would love it
if they did there are lots of things to
be honest that seem to be teased and set
up in Picard season three including
section 31 to be fair
um there's also the whole thing with
Kirk and the Phoenix and the books that
came from was inspired by maybe there's
something there the return of William
Shatner
there seems to be lots of possibilities
that are being teed up but which one of
them will Paramount actually decide to
order
now Alex kurtzman keeps talking about
and they've got lots of ideas and
they're pitching them to Paramount
constantly but at the end of the day
it's Paramount that we'll be ordering
the TV show Alex kurtzman is only the
person that will then do it
so Alex kirchman doesn't actually get to
decide and I have to say
of lots of the rumors I hear is the
Paramount Executives don't trust
kurtzman but maybe they trust metallis
but guys again to comments and tell me
what you think is a new live-action Star
Trek series a little show run by Tara
metallis something that you'd be excited
by and if so what should that show look
like I'd love for you to tell me please
get in the comments and tell me exactly
what you're thinking
if you are new to the Channel please
like subscribe hit that Bell
notification it really helps us out and
you'll never miss any of our new
episodes also you can go to patreon.com
forward slash sidetracking for a small
contribution each week that really
supports the channel you can see most of
our videos before everybody else
as always please stay safe and I'll see
you next time
[Music]